joining us now dr ben carson former hud
secretary founder
of the american cornerstone institute dr
carson
are the unions finally going to pay
a price this time are parents
going to get involved and demand that
they actually
teach in person i hope so
you know i've had a lot of very good
teachers who really helped transform me
as a student
but i think a lot of teachers are forced
into these unions
and the unions are the ones that are
really problematic they're not putting
the interest of the kids first
they're certainly not considering what
science shows
science shows that the mortality rate
for the 0 to 19 age
range group who contract covet is
.0097 that's very close to nothing
so it's really not an issue of danger
it's
obviously an issue of their preferences
and their
ideologies and those those are the
things that really have to be fought
and we need to be paying attention and
people need to be going to the
to the meetings and meeting with the
legislators and with the school board
and giving them a piece of their mind
don't let them get away with this
because who is suffering
the children and this will have a
devastating impact on them
not just for a year but for their entire
lives
and particularly the children who are
in disadvantaged situations who don't
have
computers who don't have high-speed
internet who don't have all the other
types of wrap-around services
they're going to suffer tremendously
from this do the teacher unions care
about
those individuals no well i don't think
the democrats care about those
individuals clearly i mean
at some point the democrats you have to
put it on them by the way there are a
number of
kids from pennsylvania schools
who spoke out on the damaging effects of
being out of school dr carson watch
i feel like high school was our chance
to still have our childhood and
to be kids and now we don't have that
i don't even know where like the school
life and the
just everyday home life just like is
blurred and
i feel like i'm always in school my
mental health hasn't been good
i just got a therapist you know
dr carson when will we really know the
full full effects of all this
depression suicide self-esteem
not to mention the fact that the 122
million dollars wasn't enough they want
more
and we continue to increase the national
debt
so that we can justify enormous taxes
which will destroy their future in
another way it's
almost as if they don't like our kids
they don't think about them anymore
and thomas jefferson said it was immoral
to steal from the next generation
i wish people would just settle down and
start thinking about something other
than themselves dr carson that's a great
way to end it thank you so much